Another day,
another 10th flog coffee on a Tuesday
and blog for.
For me,
it's about stories I'm drawn to art
forms that availed themselves of stories
and the development of character because
I love hearing about how people choose
to get along in their century or less of
life within stories.
There are genres and sub genres that I
find particularly interesting because of
their capacities to eliminate certain
parts of our experience that we may be
hiding from ourselves.
For example,
maybe we tell ourselves that we're free
in control,
that there's a plan or a person guiding
us,
that reality is hard,
like a stone and knowable.
It's an important function of fiction to
tear these things down.
In this vein,
one of my favorite genres is cyberpunk,
a projection of postmodernism,
which is itself a refutation of general
theories and drawing heavily on science
fiction.
Cyberpunk is a reaction to the
information age,
the age of the personal computer
established in the work of William
Gibson's neuromancer series.
Cyberpunk features the interaction of
high tech and low light as Lawrence
Pearson describes it.
Classic cyberpunk characters were
marginalized,
alienated loners who lived on the edge
of society in generally dystopic futures
were daily life was impacted by rapid
technological change and ubiquitous
datasphere computerized information and
invasive modification of the human body.
What makes cyber punk still compelling,
I think is that a lot of these things
are already prevalent.
The Internet,
social media,
artificial organs,
augmented reality,
and most recently the Google glass now
that our future will become dystopic.
Well,
that's a stretch,
but this is fiction and I don't think
it's really the point of science fiction
to be predicted.
There's a deeper level in cyber punk and
I think that it's captured best in the
film blade runner.
I think cinema is uniquely suited to
cyber punk because it has the advantages
of the visual and auditory,
the neon moving lights,
the little ting longing music of the
brilliant Vangelis.
I mean as soon as that first note goes
bad and the brilliant score to blade
runner before the credits or even over,
you know exactly what the movie is going
to convey here.
Just take alice
gives me chills every time.
Blade runner's meticulous,
romanticization of cyber punk,
I think is key to understanding its
power.
I think that the breakdown in the social
order,
the overload of information,
the sheer size and incomprehensibility
of this kind of dystopia appeals to an
important part in every one of us.
It's the desire to surrender,
to succumb to the quite apparent truth,
that everything means nothing.
It's my idea,
and I admit that it's a controversial
one,
that everyone furtively understands that
life is meaningless despite what they
profess to believe in public,
and that a moderated submission to this
chaos is in fact profoundly healthy.
Key word moderate cyberpunk allows us
away into this part of ourselves.
It reflects loneliness,
the evasion of responsibility,
and the severe impotence of man in the
mouth of the universe.
It makes chumps that of scientists and
dogmatists alike,
and though it tears down the walls I've
built to protect myself from the
largeness of nihilism,
it's at the same time a feeling of
loveliness as if I was listening to a
gentle song
and when the note turned
had melted.
Thank you for staying with me through 40
weeks of blogs.
It's been an amazing time doing these.
If you haven't subscribed,
please subscribe.
Tell people about us.
We want this community to grow and get
bigger and hopefully we can do a lot
more.